the open guys
I hope you've got a lot of good stories
Oh
basket book a guitar
give up big of mine back in the day
smoke into the basket
Thomas away by ulis are behind Douglas
over Boston College daughter happily
forever
[Music]
two three
electronic actor the drastic ulis picks
out the Aaron task just a coupie the
Booker pull-up three by Booker down sit
down look at the pull-up banks it off no
less
timeout is taken Sam I'll get the
dribbler stop Jeff shooting
it's impressive
just give it a book because he'll do
stuff like that I take it it's a pretty
athletic move here for a young player I
mean he was way up there and fallen away
smoker deadly the three
[Applause]
[Music]
prior games like this this is the point
where you really put your foot on the
gas pedal don't let them get back in the
game
smoker
score the basket Marcus had one bump
[Music]
right
[Music]
for three
and kids perfectly
[Music]
at this shot I mean this is big-time
stuff little uptaken
[Music]
[Applause]
for two more eight seconds difference
between the two clocks poker
forty-two and Counting for Booker three
fourth quarters who the Celtics have not
been good averaged less than 20 points
shooting less than 30 percent Booker has
a chance for a three-point play
of course
that's just a simply a bad pass
[Music]
Tokra base line for two he's got 47 they
said to the basket
he's got 49 and he'll get one at the
line for 50 the pic wide open they got
him the ball hooker with 52
look at her basket
[Music]
shoot again
[Music]
for Booker to the dream attrition watch
engines pull up I mean that's about 10
feet past the arc you know above the arc
what gives get 59 points to the rest of
the team has 49
going to the basket stays with it gets
to war
hooker gets free come down shoot began
New Jersey technique
till next week this is representative
and I think once he gets this and they
they can calm down
he did it and it crowd is happy so
celtic [ __ ] listen to you cry